okay hi everyone I'm happy to be here
talking about testing pandas so I'm just
going to be sharing this from a notebook
here and I've actually executed The
Notebook so for the sake of uh pleasing
the demo Gods
um
I'll just be sharing the notebook or not
running it just showing showing what it
does but I you know if we if there are
questions I am monitoring the chat so if
there are questions I'm happy to sort of
go off script if necessary so as Steve
said I I do corporate training
um and I teach people well I like to say
that I teach people to tell lies with
data and I sell snake oil for a living I
teach Python and data science for a
living I'm also an advisor at a company
called Ponder Ponder makes a version of
pandas that allows you to scale out
multiple machines so uh super excited
about the work they'd done and I also
wrote the book effective pandas which is
a best-selling book on how to leverage
pandas
um so happy to be here and thanks
everyone for watching so what we're
going to talk about today is how I test
pandas and some techniques for doing
that so if I can find my cursor here
okay here it is
um
let's get going
I'm trying to sorry my screen my screen
is kind of
being funky here
um
I'm gonna stop my screenshot and try and
share again
um
okay I'm sorry my stream yard is is
being weird let me let me see if I can
get this working
foreign
again as soon as we can
food
[Music]
hey Matt we're
hmm oh I can't hear you
can you hear me now
uh yes sir sorry about that okay so so
I'll get going here I apologize for
um that so I'm going to load some data
here and I'm just going to use pandas to
do that and
this is uh some some data from
a ski resort I'm I'm in based out of
Salt Lake and so this is a data from my
ski resort so we're just going to look
at some doing some manipulation of this
data and how we would change that so
let's let's assume that you wanted to
summarize this this is from the SQ
resort called Alta you want to summarize
this by week it right now it's daily
data and so there are various things you
might do you might want to filter out
certain columns you might want to group
by the date and then you might want to
do aggregations and then maybe you want
to make a new column maybe you want to
add the name of the ski resort maybe the
name of the ski resort changed over time
so you want to have some logic to do
that and then maybe you want a new
column with the weekly range of the date
of of the temperature
so here's how probably a lot of people
would do that that uh
you know copy the data because if they
don't copy it then they get some weird
warning and then they'd pull out some
columns and then store that in another
data frame then make this grouped object
to do the grouping that the weak
frequency and then the aggregate all the
columns at this level and store that
then maybe that's uh pull out the date
index and stick that into a column and
then the you know say if the date is
less than two thousand then maybe it's
called Alta Ski Resort if it's greater
than 2000 then it's called Alta and then
to calculate a range and when you when
you do this you get all these fun
warnings up here and it turns out that
this doesn't even work it doesn't even
put in a location call them in here
because of this fun setting with copy
warning
um so maybe they they go back and fix
that and so generally you know most uh
SAC overflow ways of fixing that involve
doing something like this instead of
doing that
um
and
um I'm also putting in some other logic
here uh to uh you know change the season
based on uh like make the season based
on the year so so that this looks like
it works and and so this is like some
basic logic here and this is probably
how most people write their pandas code
um
so so I'm I'm going to show how we can
test that and
um hopefully make it a little bit easier
to use so anyone who's read my book know
that I'm like a big fan of chaining and
so I would not write that as multiple
steps there I'd rather write it as one
long step so so here's an example of
what I do I put parentheses around that
and then in the first thing like I would
say okay I'm going to pull off my
columns and then the next thing I'd want
to do is like okay maybe I'll do a group
by so I'll just chain that inside of the
parenthetical here I'm going to group by
that and then aggregate that and then I
can run that and test that and I can do
each of these steps sort of in a chained
manner eventually I'll get something
that looks like this now this chain is a
little bit long
um you can see I I'm just doing the
reset index here I'm assigning that Alta
location and ski resort and I have some
logic down here that's a little bit more
complicated to update the season based
on the year and I'll show later how to
take clean that up but this is a chain
that that does the same thing as above
but when you run it you don't get any
warnings and you also don't have any
craft like I say intermediate variables
hanging around
um generally when I'm working with data
I'm concerned with my input and my
output I'm not really concerned with
these intermediate variables much like I
am with SQL right I write my SQL query
and SQL does a bunch of things but I
don't care about all the intermediate
things I just want the result from that
so once you once you've written it into
a chain and again you don't have to
chain but I find that after years of
writing pandas code chaining makes my
code a lot better it's really easy to
put this into a function and so here at
the I've created this function called
monthly summary
and you can see that here is my logic of
my chain right here now now here I have
uh refactored this a little bit so I've
made a git location function and get
season function and you can see that
there's the logic up there but if you
look at this chain it's relatively easy
to read you can see we take our data
frame we pull off our columns we do our
group by we aggregate the different
columns by the different aggregation
functions we reset the index we create a
t range column a location column and the
seasoning column and when we run this we
can get the output right there so so
that that is sort of what I consider
best practices starting with chaining
and sticking things into a function once
you've got it into a function you're
starting to use software engineering
best practices rather than just sticking
everything at the global level now this
allows us to do some debugging
relatively easily you know when I show
chaining a lot of people have this
visual reaction to it that it's like the
worst thing ever and they're like how do
I debug that and my comment to them is
is generally well you debug it the same
way where you debug your normal pandas
code but let me just show some examples
of debugging it one of the things a lot
of people don't know about is that
pandas has this pipe method here the
pipe is a generic method you can pass in
a function and the function we're going
to pass in takes the data frame the
current state of the data frame and can
return whatever it wants generally just
return a data frame so I can keep
chaining on top of that but here I've
got this nice little function called
size and what it does is it just prints
a an optional comment and then the shape
of the data frame so you can see I mean
to debug this is relatively easily I can
just inject these pipe calls after each
operation here this is kind of nice it's
actually pretty useful you can see that
like the first pipe called on my
original data frames so that I had 14
000 rows and 22 columns after I removed
my columns I had 14 000 rows and 12
columns and then I did a group by then I
only had 2 000 rows and five columns and
then I changed by index and you can see
that that made another column and so
this is really nice just you know to
debug what's going on along there here
I'm just looking at the size but you can
do whatever you want inside of these uh
pipe methods if you want to so I mean if
you really wanted an intermediate
variable you can do something like this
where I say and let's make a function
called store it takes a data frame of
the first argument and returns in this
case a data frame and then we're going
to pass in a name and we're just going
to make a global variable that it holds
the current state of the data frame so
if someone really wanted that
intermediate value there like I could
say and let's just stick in this pipe
call right here we're going to call the
store function and we're going to make a
variable called after group and then
after I run this it should work but if
you look down afterwards after run it we
do have this after group
that is the intermediate state if you
really want to debug that so so you know
the complaint that like you can't debug
chains
um I I think is not a valid complaint
and you can leverage pipe to certainly
debug this
um
one of the nice things about this chain
is now that it reads like a recipe right
and I'm doing each step one line at a
time and it makes it really easy to
again put it into a function and now I
can share this function with others but
I can also test it as well now that's I
mean that's kind of the 90 percent the
Pareto of like how I debug pandas code a
lot of people will see those chains and
they're like well how did you test that
I mean and it's not that I came up with
this chain and wrote the whole chain and
then run it at the end but rather I'm
doing it step by step I'm adding a line
testing it making sure it works adding
another line along the way and then the
end I will have my chain
let me show you some other techniques
that are useful you can debug with
Jupiter a lot of people aren't aware of
that so here I'm I'm going to leverage
pipe again and I'm just going to make a
another function here called debug I'm
just going to call this set Trace which
is part of IPython
um so I'm just going to stick that in
right here so after I filter my columns
right before I do my grouping I'm going
to stick in a debug there and you can
see that when I do that it puts me into
the IPython debugger so this is very
similar to pdb the python debugger that
comes with python just has a few extra
bells and whistles but I can say like L
to list where I am you can see that I am
right here in this debug line here I can
print uh my data frame if I want to and
inspect that I can go up in my stack I
can list where I am when I go up in my
stack you can see that now I'm now in
the pandas core common method there I
can go down back down to my stack I can
go to the next line I can go to the next
line again so you can you can just step
through your code if you wanted to using
this technique and it can come in very
useful right to understanding exactly
what's going on jumping into the code of
what's going on there so that that is
the IPython debugger one thing to be
aware of make sure you either quit when
you're done with that because
um
while this is running
your your jupyter notebook won't be able
to run anything else
so another thing you can do that a lot
of people don't know is you can debug
after the fact in Jupiter here so so
here I've got some code here and I you
know people are like how do you debug
something in the future well I mean
Jupiter makes it relatively easy here I
I typoed I'm grouping by date two
instead of date and so I don't have a
date too calm and when I run this I get
a key error it says like I don't know
about date two and you're like okay how
do I debug this right I mean again I'd
probably just like comment out the lines
and step through it but it but if you
didn't want to do that you can do this
sell Magic here a percent debug this is
kind of cool it just drops you into uh
the python debugger or the IPython
debugger where the exception occurred
here so I can say like L where am I and
this is where I am I'm at this line
raise key error so I can inspect the
variables at that point what is the key
the key is day two I can inspect my
object here and I can see the object
only has a date column and then I can
figure out oh yeah typo date 2 instead
of date and fix it another thing that
you can do in Jupiter if you're not
aware is you can put a double question
mark after a method or a function and
Jupiter will show you the document well
not to show you the documentation I'll
show you the source code for that which
is uh pretty useful so if you really
want to like look at the source code I'd
recommend doing it inside of Jupiter
will help you not break your flow and
stay in there
okay so so let's uh consider like
uh other types of testing that you might
want to do we've shown like how you can
create this code how you can sort of
walk through it you can debug it with
the print style debugging you can debug
it with a debugger if you want to
um let's show how you might test this so
I'm a huge fan of the pi test Library if
you don't have that installed it's a
third party Library recommend installing
them
um you know in Jupiter you can say
exclamation pip install Pi test and here
I'm just doing this all inside of
Jupiter again you don't have to do this
in Jupiter generally people would do
this in like a continuous integration
environment
foreign but I'm going to write a file so
so I'm using the cell magic here to
write a file called alta.py which just
has my logic I mean if I wanted to like
share this with other people it'd be
nice to have like a little file that you
can share and so let's just assume that
this is like the logic that I'm going to
share around right it's it's just taking
my raw data and cleaning it up
um and I'm I'm going to just uh make a
little test for this so one easy way to
do that is just say let's take my raw
data which is the data before I pass it
through this function and let's just
spit this out to a CSV text here and so
I'll just do that inside of Jupiter
right here and then I'm going to write
another file my test file here and it's
going to be called test Alta and I'm
going to import this the i o library
from the python standard library and
then I'm going to take that data that I
just created right here this the first
five lines I'm just going to throw that
directly in here as a global variable
called data and then I'll read a data
frame from that so this is basically you
know taking the first five rows and
running it through my code right my
monthly summary code and then doing an
assertion after that in this case all
I'm asserting is that the length is
equal to five that there are five rows
of data right so uh presumably this does
work
um well how do we know it works well we
have to run the test right and so to run
the test uh again because I'm inside of
Jupiter I want to Shell out to the
environment so I would say exclamation
pie test test Alta and when you do this
uh you can see that this fails
um and you can come down here and you
can see that
um it it uh was not happy with that
because it says this is only valid with
a date time index but we didn't get a
date time index we got an index here and
the issue here is that my whoops my Alta
code
I forgot to
um convert date into a date here so up
above when I read my CSV file I actually
told it to parse the dates and uh down
here when I was reading the CSV file
um I didn't parse the dates I just took
the route you can see here's here's my
DF right here and then in my logic up
above here
um right here
you can see that I'm just reading that
without parsing the date so so it
complained about that and um
but let's see if we can
uh address that and so what I'm going to
do here is I'm going to say well let's
assign date and make it a date time and
so we'll save this file we'll run our
test file again and lo and behold it now
passes right we see the period there
indicating that uh this this test was
successful so that's a basic way to take
your code
um again I I prefer chaining you don't
have to chain but I think if you try it
out you'll probably like it and then put
it into a function and then use Pi test
to write a very basic test around the
raw input and the output and and make
some assurances that the code works
okay so let's get a maybe a little bit
more complicated here there is in uh for
Jupiter a a tool called ipy test which
is kind of nice uh again third-party
tool so you'll have to install that but
I can say import ipy test and then run
this Auto config function here and then
when I have that I can just put this
cell magic ipy test at the top here and
that will run the code inside of the
cells if it were a pi test so I don't
have to Shell out to calling Pi test
which is a slightly more convenient
again uh you know if I was doing this in
configuration or pre or in continuous
integration or production I would move
these files and so you know the GitHub
action or whatever would call out and
use Pi test to run this instead of ipy
test but if you're inside of Jupiter a
nice little tool to have let's look at
some other tools that there are one is
Pandera so Pandora's a third party
library and it lets you
um make assertions about your code here
so you can install this if you need to
and then I'm going to write a little
test file called testpandera okay so
what's this going to do I'm embedding my
logic here right up here but at the
bottom here Pandera has some integration
with the hypothesis Library which is a a
property-based testing library and what
I did up here is I I read my my CSV file
right and then I I said let's use
Pandera to infer the schema from the raw
just that CSV that it read there so the
schema is like what the columns are what
their types are Etc and then it's going
to plug that into hypothesis so so I
need to do a little hookup here
um we we're going to say hypothesis
given this Pandera schema we want you to
generate basically examples of data
frames and then basically what I'm doing
is it's it hypothesis is going to to
pass that in as a fixture into my test
code the the samples that generates and
then I'm just going to run my monthly
summary function and then make
assertions about that in this case I'm
just asserting asserting that there are
nine columns in the output of that now
in this case
um
Pandera can be a little bit slow to
generate these examples here so so I did
uh
use this decoration here to add in some
other things to make a hypothesis and
Pandera not complain that it's taking
too long but but at this point I can
again shell out to Pi test if I want to
or I could use ipy tests and say test
this Pandera code and it says that it
works it also gives me a little bit of
warnings here but we'll ignore those
warnings
the Pandera code did work here's just
the example using ipy test and when you
use ipy test it it seems to give us the
same result it says that one of our
tests passed in 0.36 seconds so this is
kind of nice in that we are not hard
coding the data this case in this case
Pandera and hypothesis work together to
generate new samples and we can test our
code to see if our code works with these
new samples that it may or may not have
seen before
another library to use is called Great
Expectations somewhat similar to Pandera
Great Expectations allows you to make
assertions about uh your basically your
schema or the data that you have so the
the basic uh usage of this is you do
something like this where you say I'm
going to load the Great Expectations
library and then I'm going to take a
panda's data frame and I'm going to call
the from pandas here so we are getting
in this case uh the results of our
monthly summary right we're not not
using the raw data here but we're using
the results of that and after we do that
we can do this thing here we can say
like okay given this great expectation
data frame it's like an extension of a
data frame here has a bunch of methods
on it and you can say like I expect
column values to be between so you can
say like I want T Max to be between
negative 18 and 86. so you're generating
these expectations here and it spits out
this little Json blob from that and then
after you
here I'm just doing one of those but you
can make multiple uh
uh expectations and you can do
statistics you know that the mean is uh
within some range of some value Etc and
then you can save this uh into a suite
and
um once you have that Suite then you can
run tests against the expectations there
so here what I'm going to do is I'm
going to write a bad Json here and you
can see that I'm just like manually
changing this I'm saying like for the
T-Max I want the minimum temperature to
be 39
which I think is a little bit too high
for TMax
um
uh and and so that this is going to fail
when we run that so I'm just gonna again
use I'm going to use ipy test and I'm
just going to run my test grade
expectation test down here you can see
that down here I have a test grade
expectation and I've got a little bit of
boilerplate around this but it's
basically uh loading the Json file and
then for every expectation or test Suite
in there it's running it's as its own
test this is using pi test to do that
which is kind of cool that Pi test
rather than saying there's a bunch of
tests in there but fell on the first one
it's going to run all of the tests
individually and complain about each of
them individually here so when you run
that we can see uh that um in this case
uh this passed because I was using the
good expectation but if you want to you
could comment this out and you could uh
run this instead and we would see that
it fails uh because the temperature is
not within a certain range
um
so that I can again I can run this if we
want to so let's run that and set High
test is not found and that's because I
need to hook up the IPI test here so let
me let me quickly hook up Pi test and
I'll show this
um yeah just run this ipy test Auto
config here and then then we should be
good to go
foreign
and
it should come up with our result here
in a moment
okay
yeah and so it's complaining it says
like I expect uh this column T Max to be
between these values and
um it wasn't between those values so so
we do have a failure there so this is
just kind of nice in that like you can
basically go through all of your columns
make these assertions uh that you want
to and then once you have those made you
can now run new data you could use
hypothesis to generate new data and then
you could run that against those
assertions or you could use this to do
drift uh analysis over time
Etc
um so so again uh leverage that stick it
into Pi test stick this in a continuous
integration
um and uh certainly uh useful for
testing okay so that is that is my
content here and we got a few minutes
left
um let's see there's a question from
Patrick Patrick said uh would you make
an expectation for each function or
would you want to test in your code
you want to test
would you make an expectation for each
function in your code base or is that
Overkill
um
so here here's sort of my take on on
testing Patrick
um I kind of want to test have
assertions around the input and the
output right and so
um I want to make sure that what my uh
you know I like to make these tweak
functions that clean up my data so I
want to make assertions about like the
data that's coming out of that
um if there's anything important or I
want to make sure happens I would put an
assertion around that right
um
you know you can go down like the metric
games with like every column has to have
an assertion or whatever and then people
sort of make silly assertions just to
make assertions right so I'm more of a
lazy type where it's like uh this bit me
once I'm gonna put an assertion in here
so it doesn't bite me again and the next
time
um uh Matt Dupree says how do you choose
whether you use Pandora Great
Expectations
um they're kind of different right I
mean Pandera will generate your data for
you great expectations will will uh
allow you to say this column is between
a certain value so so different uh
functionality there
um can we access the notebook yeah if
you want access to the notebook reach
out to me either on Twitter or uh
connect with me on LinkedIn happy to get
you access to the notebook
um
uh Patrick says can hypothesis save
schemas so the data file isn't necessary
to run the test
um
so yeah you if you want to you can
manually create a schema if you wanted
to
um or you could save that if you wanted
to as well
um
yeah Matt Dupree says Kim Beck says
write tests until fear is transformed
into boredom yeah and again you could
this isn't necessarily like going down
like how people test or whether you
should do test driven development or
whatnot but showing you that like
certainly it is possible to test your
pandas code
um
okay
uh Bruno says how good is Pandera at
generating data for hypothesis
um it's okay it it actually while I was
creating this I filed a bug with them
that sped up the test uh the the
creation of uh the data frame by quite a
bit but from my point of view it's
it could be quicker
um
foreign
ludovico says do you have any
recommendation for testing Jupiter
notebooks we've used Envy make and NB of
Val so I I'm I I mean I know that like
people like GitHub or not GitHub Netflix
like put notebooks into production I'm
not that type my background is software
engineering so I'm more of a let's use
notebooks for exploration and then let's
move use software engineering best
practices make functions put it into
modules test those modules Etc
so
okay
um awesome well thanks everyone so much
again reach out to me on Twitter or
LinkedIn if you want the notebook it's
been a pleasure have a great rest of
your conference